- All right,
(audience applauding)
well, let's keep the holiday spirit going,
'cause I'm ready to kick some butt.
As you know, Jason's new movie,
"Aquaman And The Lost Kingdom"
opens on December 22nd,
just in time for Christmas.
So in honor of that, it's time
for a Christmas song edition
of Sing That Name That Tune.
♪ Sing That Name That Tune ♪
(audience applauding)
- Here to host for us,
everybody give it up for
our very own, Rubin Ervin!
(audience applauding)
(upbeat music)
Come on over.
- What's up, man?
Nice to meet you, brother.
- All right, you ready?
- I'm ready, I'm ready.
- [Kelly] I'm ready, I'm ready.
- I'm ready, I'm ready, I'm ready.
- He seems weak, right?
I can do this.
- I'm not gonna say that, he's very big.
All right, here we go.
(Kelly and audience laughing)
This is similar to the
classic Name That Tune game,
the band will play a song
and Kelly and Jason will try to guess it.
The twist is, the game, you're
gonna have to sing the tune,
not just say it.
- Okay.
- Now you get points on how
close you get to the lyrics,
and for the enthusiasm
of your performance.
So if you sing it instead of singing it,
you might get some more points, all right?
- Okay.
- Now even if you don't get it at first,
step up, sing your heart out,
and I might even still give
you a couple of points,
okay?
- I like it.
- All right.
- Personality!
Okay, cool.
- All right, let's get things going.
Kelly is playing for the
left side of the audience.
- Yes!
- Left side,
make some noise!
(audience applauding)
Jason's playing for the right side.
Right side, make some noise!
(audience applauding)
- I'm not Aquaman, I get it!
(Rubin laughs)
- The winner gets an early
Christmas gift for their side,
so here we go.
Are y'all ready?
- [Kelly] Yes, can we step up?
(audience applauding)
- Step up on the platform.
- All right, Momoa.
- All right, here we go.
Jason.
Y'all, take it away.
- [Kelly] Okay.
("Deck The Halls")
- Ooh, ooh!
♪ La, la, la, la, la ♪
♪ 'Tis the season to be jolly ♪
♪ Fa, la, la, la, la ♪
- [Rubin] That's correct!
♪ La, la, la, la ♪
(audience applauding)
- "Deck The Halls!"
I didn't even say it
yet, "Deck The Halls."
- Jason, now remember,
if you know the song,
you can just jump-
- [Kelly] You were hesitant.
- [Rubin] Do whatever, boss, do whatever.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- You were hesitant.
- Sweet baby Harambe.
All right, here we go.
Jason.
- I'm gonna kill you at this. (laughs)
- [Rubin] Next classic Christmas song.
("Jingle Bells")
(audience yelling)
Oh!
♪ Jingle, fa, da, da, da, da, da ♪
"Jingle Bells."
Yeah.
♪ Jingle bells, jingle bells ♪
- Left side, make some noise.
(bell dings)
(audience applauding)
Hey, can you do me a favor?
Can you step right here real quick for me?
Just step right here.
Just step right there
for me, cool, cool, cool.
I'ma step up here.
- Cool, cool.
- Hey, brother, you
gotta sing the song, man.
(Kelly and audience laughing)
You gotta get up here, and
you gotta sing the song, man.
- I thought whoever gets up
there first, gets to sing.
- All right, here we go, you can go back.
There you go, there you go, here we go.
- Oh my god.
(audience laughing)
- Here we go.
- I wonder what it's like to
be that powerful in a room.
- Jason, next song.
- Okay.
("Joy To The World")
♪ Let Earth receive her king ♪
♪ Let every heart prepare him room ♪
♪ And Heaven and nature sing ♪
♪ And Heaven, and Heaven and nature sing ♪
- That's how you do it.
- Yes!
(bell dings)
(audience applauding)
- That's how you do it.
- Okay.
Points for bravado, I
liked it, I liked it.
- It's technically two to one.
- Whatever.
- But that was so much extra,
it's two to two, all right?
I'm sorry.
(bell dings)
- What?
- [Rubin] I'm sorry, Kelly.
(audience applauding)
- Please, if you ever
go karaoking, invite me.
I just wanna be there.
(bells jingling)
- Okay.
Uh oh.
- It seems like we have
time for one last song.
- [Kelly] I can't.
- Who will win this,
Aquaman or the American Idol?
(audience applauding)
- Who knows?
- Jason, take it away!
("We Wish You A Merry Christmas")
♪ We wish you a merry Christmas ♪
♪ We wish you a merry Christmas
and a happy new year ♪
- Yes!
(audience applauding)
♪ I wish you a merry Christmas ♪
- That's a beautiful duet.
- [Jason] I wish you a merry Christmas.
- Merry Christmas, everybody.
(audience applauding)
I think we did it the same time.
- I wish everyone a merry Christmas,
except this guy.
- It was the same time.
And I almost let you win,
and then he grabbed my shoulder,
and I was very afraid, so Aquaman wins!
(audience applauding)
(bell dings)
(Jason cheering)
- No!
- Yeah!
Okay, whatever.
He's bigger than I am, I don't count.
Everyone is a winner here though,
especially us, 'cause
he took his shirt off.
(Kelly and audience laughing)
Yo Audio is the season's must-have
for elevating your outdoor adventure.
You're throwing it all.
"Magic Mike" moment.
It offers hands-free communication
between you and another
individual up to 2,000 feet.
That's pretty cool.
It's perfect for skiing, snowboarding,
mountain biking, cycling,
and many more action adventure sports,
and you're all going home
with a $300 gift card
from Yo Audio!
(audience applauding)
Let's hear it one more time for
Rubin Ervin and Jason Momoa!
I'm sorry.
(audience applauding)
Everybody, go see "Aquaman
And The Lost Kingdom,"
it's in theaters Friday, December 22nd.